ça a commencé par des des Brou qui
volaient on était arrosé chacun à son
tour le tiroir d'une petite table de
nuit qui a volé à plusieurs reprise les
traces d' kimos que vous portez sur la
sur la figure et bien ma je ne sais pas
qu'est-ce que j'ai reçu à la figure vous
ne vous rappelez pas oh je me Rapp
comment est-ce que vous êtes fait ça je
ne comprends rien rien rien j'ai pas
fait de mal à personne je ne crois pas
j'ai à qui j'ai pu faire du mal qui
viennne répondrait mais à quoi vous
pensez lorsque lorsque vous dites ça au
diable sans doute NONAH écoutez qui sait
qui me faire des sautises vous êtes venu
Bir la maison oui et vous êtes arrivé
une aventure je crois oui mais cela je
je ne ve pas raconter ça dans les
détails ah ben il a reçu un machin sur
la tête aussi quoi quel machin une
petite statue la statue de qui su une
hypothèse une
hypothèse ce sont des forces
occultes